hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the
things in the night okay but down that
road but there was a door that was
locked
we still frame rates are still pretty
jumpy here and I do not like this place
hahahaha that is awesome
I'll be right back though that is
awesome as beyond awesome holy crap
hello it's funny we're closing down but
they want to field us to stay down here
why
well they safe to get the place clean
but we are closing it down so it makes
no sense something isn't right Master
has returned from the village all
covered in blood he said it was a time
for the first test to begin I didn't
know what he meant by that but in fear I
just said O'Kane so did the other 12
down here with me the test has started
it isn't that bad the master said there
is three keys hidden around the archives
and then if we find them we get our
freedom all we need to do is find them
and shut down the terminals Oh God
something is roaming the halls killing
us one by one this isn't right I must
find the rest of the keys but now that
we are all split up there's almost no
hope nine of us are dead now I could
only find one key with all my bad luck I
dropped it in the upstairs housing
quarters when I was running away from
some monster god help us he never said
anything about people dying find gab
all right so I need to find me some keys
oh man the framerate it must be that
special effect he got going on out of
the room I mean that's cool and all but
it's killing my frame rates I don't know
why weird hidden anything oh I walk over
there it's just terrible oh man
that noise in the background supposed to
be a spider hey it's actually a fighter
weird so I don't see anything else here
but it did tell me that I need to find
some keys to shut down the terminal I'm
guessing to that area over there
or maybe not and let's go a wand'rin
Oh far out man is this if electro wave
is on don't enter it can cause death
yeah that's so sad
there's just instant huh almost like I
just fell asleep huh except I was dead
okay but where am I supposed to go
oh well those those are more ominous and
suggesting that I shouldn't go down that
way
that wasn't there before anyway um
well I mean there's really not that much
to go on here I mean this is the old
archive
these are the old our cut-rate wah ah no
ah baloney balderdash
whoosh Blatt at least there's actually a
point down there where you can actually
die that's the second time it's happened
to me in a custom story not this one but
another one that kind of happened that
was voluntary though when I could go
through that door I fell into the abyss
I forget what I think it was lost to
lights anyway I think this is this is
all the old archives right so that means
that here ah lock now wait but there
wasn't anywhere to go I didn't think
there was anywhere to go I mean the door
down there was locked I can't get in
there I don't have anything on me except
the real lab key boy I can pick a weak
lock ah
maybe the door down here okay alright
but apparently there's a monster down
here also killing people so that's
fantastic
really don't be a problem no no it dark
and also no framerate
where do those come from
hah huh Oh nowhere to hide in here
oh yes sirs
thank you
those statues were not there were they
Oh ray-ray
terrible
frame-rate good now props have a little
framerate recorder or counter up in the
corner there
both
oh he's so trolling me ah oh that oh oh
no oh no
is it mannequin time oh no no I'm not
ready I don't want it I don't wanna I
don't want it is he gone
you go away oh okay oh I don't wanna I
don't wanna
Oh screw you ah yeah
I saw nothing why'd I do that
picked up key
Oh Oh
I saw something do something there no
frame rate again a little high frame
rate see you go oh
huh
Who am I
what's going on this room is bright and
colorful cotton candy on the ground oh I
know like I know like ah let's screw up
your bread your potatoes if the valve
that lifts up the cage doors gets rusty
you'll have to use the back up way to
enlarge archives inside the study only
the top servants know about it you'll
have to find four special books and pull
them out you will only get a certain
amount of time to pull all four of the
books but if you are the right person
you won't have any problems with that
just be quick so that the timer doesn't
reset before you get all the books out
okay that's in the archives and the
large archives inside the study it must
be that room I got the first note I
don't know I don't know I would love
some oil any any oil Oh
that music is gonna drive me insane okay
there must be a way to get these doors
open
I will need to look for things each one
of them is lucky that's different
I've heard that before oh I am so
tripping balls
okay so just a whale
shut up oh ah come on
oh come on I'll stop it
okay locked why are you facing that way
oh I wish I had oil I've a little bit
Oh key for the large swinging door okay
huh hahaha
how do you even know what if I'm going
the right way
oh there's too much water
give me up give up give me up oh I don't
like this oh sorry I'm not very
talkative right now
I don't feel like talking
okay what am I here for what am I even
looking for out Oh body parts oh I know
it's coming oh I know what's coming
okay all right I'm okay
oh this is where I pull the books oh
okay okay I get it
I'm looking for special books oh oh
there's one okay I'm not gonna pull them
all yet until I know where they are
ah okay Oh Oh No ha ha floors lava
I've been playing this game on my life
huh Wow Oh see any others oh come on
what the hell is this Oh
I like it I don't like it we know like
it just watch the episode of how I
mother made your mother the other day
was it Tyler no likey Tyler no likey oh
it's one word I won't spoil I don't see
any other books they're very distinct
and obvious I've only seen the one ah
come on okay I'm looking man I'm looking
man
game over man ah okay Oh seriously I'm
looking I'm looking real real hard I'll
get me out there nothing ah
all right good screw it I'm out of time
so I'm Andy
screw this anyway thank you all so much
for watching and as always we'll see you
in the next part bye-bye